começou a contar a minha história e
chegar à parte da minha mãe eu eo
rodrigo sabiá sabiam o apelido que
cresceu comigo quando eu cheguei em uma
comunidade na zona sul de porto alegre e
eu peguei esse apelido e acabou criança
ficando e rodrigão se chama de rodrigo
silva já maio
liguei o útil ao agradável rodrigo sabiá
oito anos eu cheguei na comunidade pra
mim eram tudo coisas novas todo mundo
diferente a partir pra mim sabe que o
bochum flamengo comecei a ver a
violência drogas armas tv eu ouvia falar
eu estava fazendo parte da turma daqui a
pouco é com 16 anos eu comecei a sair
para a rua
como todo jovem comecei a descobrir se
essas comecei a descobrir namoradas
descobri o que era uma de marca
eu andar como o vizinho a descrição da
água com que ele tenha carício esgotados
melhores roupas as melhores roupas que
eu via na tv
o filho de mãe solteira com mais um
irmão caçula com um doméstico
eu trabalhava meu dinheiro era para
comprar as minhas coisas mas não era o
suficiente
havendo fulano andar com aquela a
queimada com uma roupa caríssima que lá
também anda aí daqui a pouco também
querendo vendê lá e comecei a achar que
era mais fácil pra andar que nem eles
eu vou à luta com eles e com um 17 para
18 anos eu cometi o primeiro delito um
furto
e assim foi ele começou a a se tornar
uma coisa cotidiana vida sabe eu daqui a
pouco largas estudos larguei meu
trabalho
e com 18 anos eu fui preso pela primeira
vez valeu o eu cresci vendo meus amigos
saírem da fase e voltarem e sair e
entrar em um presídio chega vai falar de
vocês história eu tinha curiosidade de
saber como é que há dentro de um
presídio como é que a eta e preso sabe
eu fiquei 20 dias eu matei aquela
curiosidade até a curiosidade principal
é não quero mais
não vou mais voltar foi legal
só que com 23 anos
eu voltei a cometer os mesmos delitos 23
anos eu vou te assaltar e diferente das
outras vezes na semana às vezes eu
cometia furtos três anos eu comecei a
cometer assaltos
diferente das outras vezes eu cometi
meus de litros - furtos com 11 jovens de
classe média
vamos pegar o carro do pai outro pegava
a arma do pai e agente do sul diz
eu sempre achei sempre atento ver
acontecer com fulano vai acontecer com
esse clã mais contigo nunca vai
acontecer contigo mais acontecer
aconteceu foi preso pela segunda vez é
diferente daquela outra vez não tinha
curiosidade de saber como é que era
eu não tinha a menor pretensão de preso
num não esperava empresa e fui
entrei com 23 anos esperando que eu
puder sair daqui até a gente 30 trinta
dias
não fiquei lá eu comecei a entrar em
depressão
comecei a chorar a vapor dias ele
chorava
minha mãe ia lá militar eo
estava com olheira de tanto chorar eu eu
queria poder chegar em habilitar muito
acontecendo e se nenhuma empresa que
está acontecendo filho ela achava que
estava brigando que estava apanhando sei
lá dentro sabe mas não de pressão
sabe eu não consegui assistir tv
eu não conseguia ouvir rádio tudo que
tinha relação com a vida aqui fora eu
não conseguia ter acesso no que iria
agir jornal nada porque tudo que chamava
a atenção na rua e eu não podia tá eu
não podia fazer parte desse mundo aqui
fora sabe e eu fiquei assim dias semanas
se ele tem que fugir daqui eu tenho que
fugir já que eu não consigo tirar o meu
corpo aqui dentro tem diariamente nos
pensamentos sabe eu fiquei pensando como
é que eu vou fugir disso tudo como é que
eu vou sair daqui me sentia sufocada eu
queria gritar quem sabe criar tirar
aquele peso dentro de mim e eu não
conseguia beber água sentado ali futebol
na quadra pra jogar e de um livro
segurar nenhum livro nunca li um livro
em toda a minha vida eu sempre fui uma
hora o preguiçoso para a leitura sempre
fui eu lembro que na escola eu a
professora dava trabalho para fazer e
ela lhe o resultado ea lista edital está
pronto o professor precisa ter me
conhecia já o rodrigo de novo escreveu
copiou a sinopse do livro que traz área
eu não dou minha palavra eu colocava do
jeito que estava ali sabe a e assim eu e
eu fui lá e uma semana eu li um livro
para quem nunca leu um livro porque ele
foi uma vitória sem saber marcar um gol
em final de copa e conseguir um livro
caro no livro era somos todos inocentes
na vida
ele livre daqui a pouco ele começou a
mudar minhas idéias começou a mudar meus
pensamentos
eu pensei pô eu tenho que começar a
traçar metas e começamos a traçar
objetivos para quando começar daqui e
comecei a escrever escrevia daqui a
pouco estava escrevendo versos poesias
coisas porque jamais imaginei que
conseguiria fazer sabe
jamais pensei que eu poderia escrever um
texto e eu descobrir um talento
escondido
eu comecei a procurar uma campanha
acompanhamento psicológico que eu
precisava de alguém para conversar
eu precisava de alguém pra passar minhas
idéias para me dá idéias pra trocar uma
idéia diferente porque não aguentava
mais ficar ouvindo o fulano lá falando
sobre matar sobre traficar sabendo e eu
não queria que eu liguei pra mim é o
momento de mudar
era ali dentro momento que eu tinha que
mudar
era ali dentro não adianta eu queria
quando chegar na rua vou mudar porque lá
dentro eu comecei a trabalhar e cine
em 2009 eu conheci o grupo início para a
paz dentro da pés através da junto com a
doutora fernanda bassani
são pessoas que me ajudaram incentivaram
e sempre me deram a maior força e eu
comecei aqui e no grupo eu comecei as
pessoas devem seguir para fazê la cantar
na somos todos os multiplicadores de seu
nenê que é o que diz a lei e eu comecei
a aprender sobre cultura negra eu não
conhecia nada sobre a nossa cultura
sobre a organização
aquela idéia eu fui passando aquela
ideia começou a mudar com ali dentro de
mim daqui a pouco o meu irmão também
estava preso encontrei meu irmão desde
desde 2006 e não viu o irmão sabe a
gente muito foi muito ligado assim sabe
eu não vi meu irmão eu encontrei ele
a gente conseguiu reunir a nossa família
dele e à minha mãe meu irmão dentro de
uma cadeia
a gente conversava assim pouca gente tem
que sair daqui
quem tem que fazer algo pela nossa mãe
dá uma alegria pra ela ela passou cinco
anos um sacola pesado em nos visitar
durante cinco anos
eu falei não eu não quero ajudar
só não quero ajudar o meu próximo quero
dar os meus amigos porque de 30 amigos
acho que se eu contava de dalí 5 que
incidiram caminhos e artesã seguir o
caminho do crime e não tão morto hoje
estão presas
eu quero mudar isso em mim eu quero
mudar isso meus amigos daqui a pouco eu
saí e consegui um trabalho pra
contrariar uma cooperativa uma
cooperativa de reciclagem de lixo
separar lixo dos outros como é que eu
vou fazer pra falar pra pessoa que não
eu não quero trabalhar no lixo como é
que palavra que eu usar aqui que eu vou
falar
sabe eu fiquei pensando de do dois dias
eu fiquei pensando no total ele teria
trabalhado mais claro que é um pouco e
passa pela cabeça pois tudo que eu
queria era uma oportunidade para
trabalhar e apareceu a oportunidade quem
sabe daqui a pouco fui lá comecei a
trabalhar como tomei gosto pela coisa eu
fiquei ali eu podia tirar coisas buzzi e
que eu podia me ajudar e ajudar outras
pessoas
eu falei para meu espanto um pouco eu
quero abrir o meu próprio galpão de
reciclagem ajuda orienta me dá ensina e
ele foi lá me ensinou daqui a pouco vem
mesmo trabalhar ea gente falou para a
gente tem que abrir nosso próprio campo
disse lage
depois de muito trabalho muito suor sabe
trabalhar de sol a sol coisa que eu
nunca tinha vindo feito na minha vida
a gente abre o nosso próprio com hoje
faz cinco anos que a gente tem nosso
balcão e por lá a gente teve a
oportunidade de poder dá trabalho para
outros jovens projovem igual a nós
que também um não tiveram oportunidade o
que saiu na do sistema penitenciário
foram a trabalhar com nós hoje a gente
tem três jovens trabalham com nós só que
por lá já passaram 50 e é gratificante
cada vez que eu passo o encontrou na rua
ou vejo um que tá bem tá trabalhando em
outra área conseguiu estudar sabe ele
que aquele dinheirinho que ele ganhava
lá com a gente lá conosco serviu serviu
para ele mudar a vida dele
de alguma forma correr atrás de outras
coisas de outros objetivos dos
residentes e
isso pra mim pô é uma realização de um
sonho sabe eu consegui dar a volta por
cima e conseguir dar uma alegria pra
minha mãe conseguir eu estou aqui hoje
por causa dela como eu falei no início
ela que praticamente me trouxe pela
montadora e de cada vez que eu escuto
uma história que fala do tiago falando
avó dele eu emociona eu lembro da minha
mãe porque sempre foi uma grande
guerreira que sempre sonhou e batalhou
muito por nós
hoje ela quase 60 anos ela tem dois
filhos adotivos
sáb 2 alemãozinho assim eu estava
falando ele o início porém é na casa
assunto negão e chega dois alemãozinho
as pessoas ficam olhando assim as
teorias esse dia chega um cara ligado no
220 já estava chegando em casa eu
cheguei lá a minha mãe da idéia e um
deles me deu ele foi na creche e chegou
e me deu um trabalho em que dizia assim
obrigado por ser um exemplo pra mim
o barco vai deixar comigo
e eu que em casa e comida na geladeira
lá está até hoje lá e eu eo principal
recolheu quase chorei ficou trancada que
assim eu por ser um evento para aqueles
dois
é um incentivo a mais para correr atrás
para o soar mais e cada vez que até hoje
eu sou agora não mais até poucos anos
atrás as pessoas devem embarcar em uma
fita lá está hoje não sabe que eu sou
totalmente fora mas até alguns anos
atrás de vinho o flamengo tem uma fita
lá pra fazer não quer e não quer só nos
levar de carro há as pessoas procuram
sabe que ninguém nunca foi me procurar
para dar um emprego em que nunca foi
procurado para dar um trabalho
eu fico triste puro todos os amigos e
ver a situação deles e por diversas
vezes chega e fala barra eu queria poder
e corrido atrás que nem conseguiu ter
vencido a apresentação que nem todo em
silwan e já vi vários para trabalhar
comigo mas eles não conseguiram
hoje estou montando uma cooperativa onde
eu quero dar
oportunidades para outros presos para
outros jovens jovens de da fase jovem
abrigo
eu estou correndo os papéis tudo pra
fazer isso porque a gente tem que dar
oportunidade a gente tem que incentiva a
gente a gente chegar e conseguir se
acomodar porque tem uma pessoa lá atrás
tem outros esperando uma oportunidade
para uma chance ea mesma oportunidade
que me foi dada
eu quero poder dar pra outros amigos
todo jovem tem amigo não rapazes que
querem uma oportunidade quero uma chance
ea cada dia que passa é uma é uma luta
diferente sabe que o e hoje me orgulho
muito em dizer que eu sou reciclador
muito e falar eu sou reciclador por
diversas vezes chegam os lugares chegar
lá o seu doutorado nisso eu sou louco de
vergonha reciclador nicho de vocês com o
maior orgulho
de alguma forma a gente recicla vidas
são recicladores de vida
tem uma frase que minha mãe fala muito e
foi então reciclador no rio e isso está
fazendo o bem para outras pessoas
e quando está a serviço do nosso próximo
de nosso deus lá em cima sabe então isso
dá um alívio assim é fácil porque às
vezes eu faço nada mas nada que as vezes
que a gente faz é de grande ajuda para o
nosso próximo dia de grande é e grega dá
um alívio muito grande quando isso
acontecer é necessário
me sinto bem a gente fazer o bem é legal
fazer o bem faz bem sabe então são essas
palavras muito obrigado a todos